hey caitlin hey evan sometimes
do you just need to take a break from
everything and just play an amusing card
game
i do
[Music]
also last episode we forgot some music
so now yeah so now we're actually going
to try doing everything live
i have a sound board
which anyone who's watched the streams
knows we have these sound boards i
i don't know why we added the podcast
music in post always
yeah we can do things live do things
live and now i won't forget to add the
thing of the week music anymore while we
bob our heads in awkward silence
it's gonna be great thank you i'm glad
thank you for your enthusiasm yes yes
we work very hard
so today it's exciting we actually have
some
updates on various things before we get
into the main
topic which is going to be another um
iteration of the card game that we play
but this one says it's all amusing it's
the amusing edition
and i'm very excited for the very first
one
can i share one yeah dance the story of
your childhood
oh gosh
so for context though this is a card
game there's different editions family
edition friends edition relationship
edition and we've played
some of those in the past usually
they're they're all very deep and
serious serious
this one wants us to dance the story of
our childhood
i already have some ideas yeah well
maybe that'll be the first one we do
after uh we go through some updates so
so it's nice we have been kind of like
honestly for the longest time over the
past three years we just
film videos and the projects just get
set aside
abandoned and i feel kind of bad they
don't always get abandoned
that makes it sound like we never use
the things we make we sometimes get
put in the guest room but we yeah and
definitely we hung our resin paintings
we did great we helped the bob ross
enjoy them when we walk by them every
time
yes above my son it did start to bulge a
little bit i don't know what that's
about oh yeah that is weird i don't know
why the resin bulged above your side was
it like that
i don't remember it being like that
until like a couple days later it kept
on evolving
and growing yeah is there uncured resin
under that
probably and
one reason why we're able to get our
life a little bit more under control
is in the future we're gonna start
scheduling
less videos i'm not sure how many videos
we're actually going to output
but for the longest time we
i don't know can i do a big disclaimer
here
because this might sound like broken
record because we have come on here
before
we have a whole episode that's just like
getting our life back together
to prevent and we've talked about like
preventing burnout a lot
and any of our family members can tell
you
that here on repeat from us is like
things have been really crazy but like
we're getting things in order like we're
getting our life in order
we've we've not scheduled ourselves so
much
and then the next day they hear we could
have over scheduled ourselves a little
bit yeah sometimes
crazy right now these are crazy right
now but they're getting better
and that's how it's been for like two
years
yeah the first year we just knew it was
crazy we just knew it was gonna be crazy
yeah yeah um yeah but we've
we've been doing these like we've been
on this roller coaster of
um things getting crazier and then
getting slightly less crazy and then
crazier and slightly less crazy and
overall the roller coaster is
slowing well also we've been adding all
these things we've been adding streams
we've been setting new things up there's
a lot of new things that have come up
like
we did we did some bonus cooking videos
that added to the schedule and
everything like that
we started doing garage streams a lot
more frequently but we've we've learned
a lot of different ways we have failed
at reducing our schedule so this this
next attempt
at not burning ourselves or you know
burning too much of the candle that we
have i don't think we've ever really
seriously approached burnout but there
have been times
where i have felt like a wet rag that
has been rung too much or something like
that i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that's the right analogy
but i feel
have felt so drained it's
because we have been seeing growth
because good things have been happening
all of that work means something and
it's worth it
but there definitely will be a point in
our lives where i know
that we need to like preemptively slow
down a little bit we can't work seven
days a week
all day forever yeah yeah we know we
can't do that forever
um so we we have gradually
been trying to slow down and then we'll
slip and we'll
yeah like the past two months we've been
we've been producing videos at a
schedule we were a year ago when we said
we really need to slow down
yeah um but hopefully maybe you guys can
like
if we start making too many videos on
our main channel say hey
you said you were going to stop no no no
no no no so yeah we are trying to reduce
uh and we did it around the beginning of
quarantine we
started doing every other week videos
that was great
that was really great well i think
another thing that that's kind of what
we're going back to
one thing that's going to help and hurt
with this
attempt to slow down is our evolving
views on our second channel
yes which is something we wanted to talk
about because the second channel
went pretty much entirely neglected
for most of our youtube career yes
we posted a a few little tiny like april
fool's thing yeah a little april fool's
video i made you something for your
birthday
mm-hmm anniversary oh yeah yeah yeah our
12th
april 12th yeah april 12th april 12th
anniversary um and we didn't really do
too much else there because
it's kind of like this you know mental
cycle where it's like
you don't have too many subs there you
don't get too many views there because
you don't put
any videos up but then you don't really
want to put up videos
there because you don't really have any
subs or views yeah and that
started changing when we started doing
garage we call them garage streams but
it's basically
it's streams in our garage live streams
from our garage yeah
and we started just putting the full
uncut streams on the second channel in
the same way that we put
uncut gaming streams on the uncut gaming
channel
and they're actually doing pretty well
and the
that channel has like finally started to
get some views and grows
and grow again so it's made us think
more about
things we would want to do on a second
channel which
can be super experimental yeah and
and and it's exciting because you know
our main channel videos
they take a long time the one we're
about to release
after you listen to this we'll have the
ball
started rolling three months three
months
you know before the video is published
you know
so that's an extreme example but yeah
the main channel videos take a long time
to set up with
the ideas the sponsors all of that but
we were
watching a video recently and they
talked about
how their editing for the last video
took five hours to edit five
whole grueling hours and i was like
that would be your shortest edit ever
that would be my short
except for like the very quick two
minute second channel videos
oh yeah yeah yeah but on the main
channel oh never
a five hour edit would be like sonic
speed
sonic speed sonic speed yeah like that's
it's insane they take me like at least
15 hours i
i know i'm i'm pretty sure that many
have taken you about 30 hours
yeah i tend to find i heard this once
and it tends to like generally ring true
for me
ish like you can expect to take at least
an
hour of editing for a minute of footage
and like the 30 minute edits take around
30 hours the 15 minute edits take around
15 hours oh that's that's what i mean
it scales with the amount of time the
edit is
um and then getting all the music right
and this is like
fast caitlyn i've gotten a lot faster
she has yeah
yeah you've gotten really good um
we started talking about um oh the
second channel the second channel so so
the fur the main channel videos take so
much prep ahead of time all that stuff
second channel videos the great thing
about them is like if we have some time
like if we free up enough time
instead of like putting more main
channel videos in there we might do some
second channel videos and since
they have been doing well we feel kind
of justified
to do that and we have a lot of fun with
them we have a lot of fun ideas
we've started brainstorming second
channel ideas and sounds so fun i am
so excited about so many of them they're
gonna be
great and it's it's interesting because
like i can i can see this getting two
types of responses one type of response
is people saying i want more main
channel videos don't
don't waste time and put time into
second channel videos just put that time
instead
into main channel videos there's also
going to be a camp of people that are
like
if the second channel type stuff is what
you want to do just do that on the main
channel
yeah and it's hard because you know to
the the first
the first person that you know is the
type that just wants us to put all the
time into the main channel
they don't like the gaming they don't
really care about the podcast they just
want more main channel videos but the
thing is we can
we can produce like two three
four we can produce like a month of
gaming content for the time it takes to
do
one main channel and also probably the
same for our second channel videos we
can do like
probably four or five second channel
videos in the time it takes for one
main channel video and those second
channel videos are gonna be really fun
and they're going to have a lot of
elements that our main channel videos
have
and i think it's just also it's like
this is our evolution
we are doing a lot of this so that we
have fun and if we are not having fun
we're not going to be making good videos
yeah so i think in the end this is in
the interest of everybody and i feel
like we often learn a lot from
going outside of our norm like when we
started doing the gaming videos
um like i mean we hire out the gaming
edits um but i feel like
like i adjusted my main editing style
um because of like changes and things
that i saw our gaming editors do but we
also
changed the way we film a lot of scenes
in our main channel videos because of
streaming
yeah because we like we had to get used
to
just going and going live
and not taking the time to say like wait
stop can we like
redo how we just did that thing it's all
live honestly podcasts were our stepping
stone to that
podcast was our stepping stone yeah um
but
yeah so i feel like even you know
doing stuff on the second channel even
if it's totally unrelated to
making or diy i think it'll help us
evolve and learn more things yeah so i
mean even
even this right now i mean this is
interesting
this podcast we used to record it
and then we would need to edit it a ton
when we first started so much editing
the podcast used to take us a whole day
and now we're at the point where
this green screen is live we're not
doing it in post because
i we i worked so hard to finesse
so long finesse our green screen until
it's really good
and and i did that because of gaming but
then podcasting is benefiting from it we
can do podcasts
faster and more streamlined because of
all of these things we've done
and now that the the second channel
has kind of proven its worth to us we
like it
you know the the general audience that
we're putting it out to is generally
liking it
now we can invest you know when we first
pitched it as an idea to ourselves we
reused equipment and we kind of threw it
together
every time with components from the
stuff we already have
for the garage for the gross live
streams but yeah like like right now
we're investing like thousands of
dollars in the setup out there
set this thing down it'll have
everything plugged in
oh i the stuff is weird we're not having
to swap components between like this
system and that garage streaming system
but but it is great because
it all fuels itself it all advances but
it's so funny that we started talking
about all this because we're like
we're going to do less videos and we're
like and since we're doing less videos
we can do more videos
yeah in terms of time and we're going to
get our life together in between the two
like yeah we want to like want to build
a little bit of a lead on the main
channel when also we need to like
plug a leak in our attic we're like
oh yeah rodents are getting in and bugs
are getting in we were in the garage
last night and we could hear something
in the
garage attic yeah crawling these are the
things that like we just kind of put off
because they're not like primary
importance but there's a lot of things
all over the place not just like with
our house but with everything we're like
we kind of put our lives in secondary
place
behind our work and we're really excited
to
make some of that a priority again
working out again a little bit more
we did we did so good once we got the
everyday calendar
and then they've slowly trailed off and
then in this past week we haven't worked
out at all
oh it's bad but i'm excited about it
yeah that that's kind of a
the big life update that took a lot
longer than i initially planned for
but yeah well i'm gonna extend it a
little bit further yeah go for it
this is fun i like this because going
back to like
you know there's also gonna be um
you know people that are super super
supportive and are like just
you know the types of things you're
thinking about the second channel why
not just do those on the main channel
just like whatever you like
and like we we go back and forth about
it
because the cooking cooking videos are
something that were
they they were the um second channel
ideas that were close enough the closest
to
our main channel type of content that
we're like maybe we can test it out
and we did four yep
and they did decently
the cheese actually did much better than
expected there are two
huge negatives though and i want to get
do you want to finish your thoughts too
because i have
i was just going to say like i think the
hard thing is
like i think we confuse the algorithm a
little bit so i think like if we're
gonna
do those we tried to do one a month
for like four months yeah and i think
we were confusing the algorithm and
confusing our audience a little bit and
the people that watched them
loved them um but they did get low
reviews and they do still take a decent
amount of time not as much as it may
like a project but a significant
fraction significantly sometimes
two-thirds and as much as some projects
yeah like doing the blindfold baking
took as much
time as the ocean soap yeah and it got
half the views
and it's not all about views no but it's
like when we when we're in the process
of trying to like get our life better in
balance
and you're looking at what you can cut
you're
you know you do have to kind of take
that into account a little bit
but also it's confusing to our sponsors
you know sponsors are still a huge
percent of our income
and when you look at our channel and
there's these
big dips every now and then we can't
like easily express like
we knew that those were going to perform
less and we were okay with it
and we know what videos are going to do
better and which ones are going to do
worse so
don't worry we'll put you on a good one
the good one you know it's like
you can't really say that to sponsors
and
you know it's hard to communicate that
and some sponsors and agencies we have
that relationship
and that's cool but like you know we're
it's it's different pitching to new
sponsors it's kind of harder to be like
oh and you'll notice that some of these
videos get like a third of
the views as usual that's totally normal
totally normal and we expected that we
won't put you on one of those
you know like yeah but also it's
confusing to people who are coming to
our channel
like new people coming because we're
getting
like multiple thousands per day
sometimes
sometimes yeah and it's i think it's a
i don't worry too much about it being
confusing because like
in my ideal world we would do a wider
variety of stuff on the main channel and
that would be
cool i think the main thing is i think
uh for a little bit there we are doing
it
too frequently and so like i'm still
down to do
cooking videos like here and there but i
think we were trying to force it too
fast
yeah maybe you know yeah we'll see we'll
see we'll see like in a few months we
did like four cooking videos
yeah it's kind of lot a lot considering
our outputs
you know our like video schedule yeah
but yeah
it's all a learning process i mean you
know i think the very first podcast we
did is we've changed or something like
that and yeah we've done like
multiple changes episodes and that's
natural we are humans we are evolving
and growing
as our interests change and as our skill
set changes
and all of that so it's good it's
natural
yeah so should we jump into the main
main chunk of the main meat yeah are you
ready to dance the story of your
childhood
i'm sorry for audio listeners i'll try
to describe it for audio
i'll try to describe it let me watch you
are you flipping a book you're reading
are you i would say that's video games
but you're flipping a book
is it video games yeah how come your
hands one hand is going up and one hand
is going down that's not how you do a
controller
yeah so it's reading and dancing wait
dancing reading and playing video games
that is the dance of my childhood yeah i
i'm surprised you didn't
well swimming was more high school
swimming was more high school and you
know
when i was a kid too um oh yeah i i
should have thrown in some backstroke
in that mix i missed that beat that was
a missed opportunity
but i was a weird kid
a little bit i was a little bit weird in
my own head
and like we would be
like my family traveled a lot because my
dad worked overseas and
on our way back home we would like
travel to all these places but i'd be
like in paris
and like just reading a little book you
know it's like oh you're in paris see
the things do the things
when you're a kid you don't fully like
have the
like full context of like how cool that
is and how rare that is
you know for like a kid to be traveling
that much and you guys traveled a lot
with your dad's work
and i wonder like if if
that might have desensitized me to going
places and seeing things
because i love traveling and i love
being in cool places and
experiencing them but is going from
place to place into seeing something you
mean
like sightseeing sightseeing yeah it's
not my favorite thing
i don't really like sightseeing
specifically either so i'm kind of the
same but i like traveling but i don't
like sightseeing specifically
but i didn't travel like internationally
maybe it's just like is it your thing or
not who knows yeah all right caitlin
it's time
the dance of my time dance the dance of
your childhood mine
isn't really a dance as a slow as much
as a slow skit
a slow skip i mean i can dance the skit
a little bit
okay i'll describe it okay i'll be the
narrator
i have to stand up
she's waiting hi um uh i'm caitlin i
just moved here
from this other state uh
i'll go i'll sit down now that's me
being the new student
every two years that's your dance that's
my dance the dance
of moving the dance of moving a bunch
there's a lot of different schools i
think this would be caitlyn's dance
drawing oh yeah i guess like to me that
didn't really start
i didn't really get super into it till i
was like 13. oh
but i guess the moving continued wow you
did all of that like caitlyn has
binders like multiple thick
three to four inch binders full of the
art that she's
started getting really into a drink at
around 13. yeah that's when i started
really getting into like
zelda fan art yeah yeah that's
impressive
thank you oh my gosh what what
i saw the next one what is it i know
that i'm just reading all of them
because they're in front of me i'm sorry
about
caitlyn yes i'm going to read this to
you you have five seconds
to start okay sing what you think the
inside of my brain sounds like
it's more like oh that's not really
singing
oh here's another what's this what's
this there's something in the air
what's this technology over there what's
this that's
it um caitlin's is like
chunka chunk jungkook chunk chunk
chunk chunk caitlyn i'm focused
focused and methodical
like the inside of her brain is
like like a logic gate system and she
can really just like focus
and not get distracted it's so weird
it's so weird because we are
so opposite in that regard it's like
we're
we're very compatible yeah and
complementary in that way yeah
but that's that's funny i think that's
one reason why like
you know we've talked about kind of like
our different responsibilities for the
business
like editing takes a long time and it's
a task you have to just like get into
and stay into
yeah and so like we can have a day where
i edit and that's all i do
and evan checks off 20 miscellaneous
things from the list
for me if i have to if i have a day
where i have to check off 20 different
miscellaneous things i get like
i'm a little stressed out i don't really
know where to start and i don't like it
as much yeah you like it
it's fun okay
this is hilarious because it's too close
to reality
if you and i were isolated alone for a
year what would you feel
like would be the best part
okay so it has been almost a year of us
basically i isolated yeah even more so
than we were
in the before times in the before time
which we were pretty isolated then too
yeah it's it's been fun yeah i mean
honestly it's like having a constant
sleepover
like you know i wish that the world
wasn't like this yeah but
we are with our best friend you know and
we are each other's like everything even
before this we
we decided we wanted to quit our day
jobs and work from home
together so that we could spend more
time together so together
like we enjoy it yeah i mean
you know that you know that feeling that
you get during a sleepover where you're
trying to go to sleep
and you just keep on talking like
because your best friend is there and
you're like ooh this is fun
we do that all the time yeah it's it's
great yeah
and we're also like each other's
cheerleaders
too yeah we're like yeah that's a good
evan you did so good with that green
screen and i'm like katelyn that edit
was so good
yeah yeah
so it's it's pretty sweet that's pretty
sweet again not that we
are happy that that is everyone's
reality right now but no but
this card was like assuming that like
if if if you were doing this with
someone that wasn't
like us that would be different like
like a big thing but no this is
our reality yeah do you want to choose
one
um yeah do you have a preference for no
i i hadn't really read them
okay so you're gonna surprise me with it
i'm ready hit me with something amusing
you can go through them if you don't
like the top card it's okay
we can just what's your favorite sound
why please please enact
enact it my favorite sound i can list
some it can just be one you like
that's a great one for anyone that
doesn't know that's that's jube
right that's tube that's true that's 100
when she's moving
i'm thinking of other sounds it's jube
when she's meowing and running at the
same time
so she's doing one long meow while
running going
and she's basically just doing a solid
yeah
but because she's running and she has a
little bit of a little bit of belly
fluff that's kind of going back and
forth
yeah um well basically all of juby's
noises
my brain went to jube as well that
specific meow
the running meow is pretty great it's
also kind of her hand meows too
every now and then when you're like like
sleeping or napping
you just go oh yeah i do that yeah
i think that's really cute thank you uh
that's okay so what's
your your favorite sounds are probably
druby all related to yeah i mean the ham
meow
and the um the
well one of my favorite sounds is
actually my ham call
hmm yeah i can't i can't do it
loudly because she'll hear it and she'll
want ham
but it's in it's in the ham wheel the
catwheel
episode but it's like
and i just want to say
[Music]
sorry i'm doing it super quietly because
like if she hears it
she will come and if we don't have ham
it dilutes
the power of the ham call and you can't
do that but that's like one of my
favorite
noises which sounds weird because it's a
noise that i make but
it's fun to make it's my favorite noise
to make yeah okay
what's something you weirdly find
comfort in that others may not
um this
sounds kind of weird
to say because it can
go like
it's comforting when you're kind of
on like the edge of it sort of but i've
lived in a lot of places
where there's like you get bad storms
like hurricanes
[Music]
and like there's
something about like ooh the
roads have six inches of water on them
so no one can go to work
or no one can go to school because it's
a bad storm when it's like not bad
enough
that it's actually causing
huge issues but it's like bad enough
that you can't leave your house
that's nice right i find comfort in that
too when it's like
or it's like kind of exciting okay okay
this is another weird thing
this is another weird thing and maybe
it's because we i traveled a lot maybe
it's because we moved a lot but i think
there's something we both find
like some comfort and joy in that's
weird
when you wake up really early but for a
really good reason
and it's like dark and quiet out and no
one else is awake it's a 5 am trip to
there yeah the
5 a.m trip to the airport and stuff like
that i wouldn't want to do it every day
but like when you're doing it for like
like christmas
morning trip or like a vacation or
something like that like
i just find like i just get like like
good tingles or like i just feel like i
was like
i like it so much a related thing
is um so we go on night walks
and part of that is because like texas
is hot a lot
part of it's because we often don't
finish up work until
it's late but like when i say night
walks sometimes that's 9 p.m
sometimes that's 1 8. and like
the later it is when we go on a walk the
more oddly comforting it is
because like no one is outside it's a
weird thing to do frankly to just walk
around
your neighborhood streets at like one in
the morning it feels it feels a little
weird but it's also oddly comforting
it is all the comforting sorry i'm
looking through some there's some
there's some good ones in here
and there's some bad ones in this deck
honestly like
some of these are just they're good
cards but they're not really amusing
like
pretend i lost all of my memory and
explain the concept of love to me
oh that's like deep yeah it's not really
like amusing
they were here for amusing today i guess
you could try to make it amusing
but i don't really know how yeah if i
was a texture
what would i be and why beard
beard you would be a blanket oh thank
you
i'm cozy cozy yeah
my first instinct was beard maybe it's
cause like i pet your beard
i'll just come by and i'll give you like
little beard pets
it's nice it's nice okay
re-enact a memory from my life and see
if i can guess it
a memory from your life a memory from my
life so does that mean it can't
be a shared memory oh
or could it be a memory we've shared it
can be a memory we've shared
okay um
this will be more fun i think if it's
something that the audience might have
heard us
talk about oh
yeah i was i like one of my first
instincts
i don't know if i could have or should
have done it but
you're like 26th birthday party oh my
24th
24th birthday party oh that was fun how
would you interact or how would you
how would you i'll just hop up on a
piano and shake my booty
24th birthday was at a dueling piano bar
it was
it was fun but but here's the thing it
was more unique because
it wasn't that about the location it was
unique memory and i'm surprised that
this wasn't
to enact it you would need to grab a
prop because the thing was
you and my mom who was also there like
gathered hundreds of problems hundreds
of props
hundreds of like little props and
costumes parts and accessories
and so everyone was wearing like crazy
glasses and hats and wigs
mustaches mustaches and jewelry you know
fake jewelry like you guys just raided
party city
was that also the time when like someone
grabbed the biggest granny panties ever
and like i think so that was someone
else's birthday and they had giant
granny panties and me and two of my
friends
all got into granny panties like in a
single pair
i remember that we all squeezed in
time yeah so great that your mom was
there
i know well you and my mom were like the
mastermind we weren't we were like
i i i i was like sneaking around i was
visiting yeah and i had to like run to
like party city and i was coordinating
with her
mom would often come out like yeah on
evenings out with us in the friend group
it was great yeah those fun times okay
so i gave you a lot of time to think of
a great memory yeah but i was
reliving really living the birthday
party
um so should i should i think of one
that it like
i guess you did one from before from
before the channel
whatever strikes your fancy
we're gonna like what one thought that i
thought of is like me falling through
the ceiling
yeah i thought of that too and my
reenactment was gonna be
well so i've watched that clip so many
times so my reaction was gonna be
so most ceiling joists are spaced 24
inches apart
and then crack because i know what you
were saying
right in the moment the first time we
were re-watching that
that made us like sweaty and nervous and
like
yeah yeah it actually we we did a whole
podcast about it actually about the
experience of it
it was called like evan falls through
the ceiling and we rethink our lives
or something but it was honestly really
scary like we can joke about it now and
laugh about it now and i feel like it's
almost part of like
channel lore but the same time it was
it's like oh
gosh um okay moving on
reenact your favorite scene from a movie
it's not going to be my favorite scene
from a movie but i just
seen and i can try to guess it i just
want to do it okay
he's looking behind him i'm i'm
stretching my butt oh you're stretching
your butt oh
nacho libre yeah
oh yeah sorry the audio of just me is
saying oh you're stretching your butt
[Laughter]
that's great you're you're you're posing
with
your booty towards the camera sometimes
the man wears stretchy pants
it's fun quotable movies are some of the
best
not julio was great but your favorite is
kung pao
my favorite is space balls yeah i also
uh
when will now become then
i also do a lot of money python quoting
a lot of money both of us do money
python yeah yeah
so um you know like it's just a flesh
wound
system or just like
i'm not i fought in your general
direction your mother was a hamster and
your father smelled of elderberries
yeah my re-enactment is mostly just
quotes of movies that i really like
[Music]
sometimes especially the kung pao ones
are like even
more i don't know like monty python i
feel like that's more well known
some of the kung pao ones are kind of
obscure but people still catch it every
now and then
okay this is something that i can't do
for you but you can do for me very
easily
okay do your best impression of me
looking for
something i lost caitlyn have you seen
my earbuds
did you check the couch cushions oh yeah
they're there
[Laughter]
it's accurate hey one time you lost your
phone and i used technology to find it
you did mm-hmm probably more than once
probably more than once still pretty
infrequently compared to how many times
i help you find
things it doesn't even compare
this like some of these aren't amusing
what's the wisest thing someone told you
i actually do have an answer to that one
though so i think uh
i don't know it's just like one that i
especially think of
like since we've been running our own
business but a thing that my
dad would say is like uh
like the harder i work the luckier i get
and it's kind of like
true you know it's like what we
where we've gotten is a mixture of work
and luck
but the harder you the more work you put
in the more likely you're able to find
yourself
in lucky youtube is basically the
epitome of that because the more videos
you put out
the more chances you have that something
catches to get lucky but you know
yeah yeah yeah oh this is this isn't
amusing but this is this stands out to
me very vividly describe the first time
you understood romantic love
i thought i understood love a lot but
like really
i first understood it truly
when we very first are dating yeah same
i thought i understood it i understood
like what it was
actually supposed to be like fully when
we started dating yeah when we started
dating i was like
it's like
[Music]
duh yeah yeah so
these are in like the like those feel
more like
deeper conversations this is for
amusement this is for amusement
make the sound of my personality
i feel like we already had that one no
that was like the sound of what goes on
in your brain oh yeah
i have the sound of our relationship
what's that it won't make sense to
anyone else really i don't think
all the time we are like
called to each other which means like
hey are you in there or hey
can you come over hey i have something
to tell you or just like anything
any acknowledgement of each other is one
of us will
and the other one will go huh yeah it's
like it's like echolocation
yeah and it's like like if caitlyn's
listening to a podcast
instead of saying like hey caitlin can
you pause it for a little bit i want to
ask you something i'm like
and she'll like yeah or like hey do you
have a second yeah
that's great right this is a great
signal
um what truly surprises you most about
people that's that's a deep question
that's a deep question yeah what do most
people misunderstand
about too deep if you want deep
deep questions go to the other card game
podcasts oh this is like this is the
opposite of abusing when's the first
what's the first time he realized
your mortality um um
hello no no what's the most ridiculous
thing you've seen me do
yes you go first okay
so the most ridiculous thing i've seen
you do
yes i'm trying to brainstorm for you
i'm trying to brainstorm for you most
ridiculous
but like in what way i mean we do
silly weird things all the time like one
that pops in my head because we post
about on social media the other day is
when you
when you when i was in your pants put
your pulled my pants all the way up to
your shoulders and you ran around
like a little like creature yeah
the most ridiculous
thing you do
yeah i think it's hard when you're like
often ridiculous also our
like our definition definition of
ridiculous
is totally different
[Music]
again my brain also kind of goes back to
like the party
parties and stuff oh yeah
but i think some of those are
stories not to be fully
they're they're for us are stories just
for us
mad hatter were you thinking mad hatter
i was thinking of your birthday
surprise oh yeah yeah yeah the surprise
uh drunken cake yeah drunken cake
yeah i think we can say that like what
you made
yeah i was actually thinking this could
be like a funny story for a whole
podcast
if we wanted to go into it oh yeah but
briefly i anyone remember epic meal time
i made an epic meal time with style cake
with some friends for evan's birthday it
was great
we can never share that video it's not
appropriate like at all
but we can tell the story yeah okay well
we'll tell that story sometime yeah
describe what you think i will be like
at 80.
i mean honestly i don't see you changing
like you're gonna be the same
i think so we're i i i want to be the
same and i think that we will be
yeah i don't see us changing that much i
like we we haven't gotten serious in our
30s
yeah like we're
i like who we are and we have both been
people who analyze ourselves a lot
and i think i'm good yeah i don't really
really want to change more yeah and
that's
you know i mean that doesn't mean not
changes and like
not evolve and like
like we still like are constantly
self analyzing and trying to improve
things about our life and
this and that but i don't think that our
wanting to do that
will change you know what i mean so it's
kind of different it's not like i'm
never gonna change
yeah but it's like your personality will
be
the same yeah yeah still having fun with
life yeah you know describe what you
think i was like when i was seven years
old
you were taking apart remote controls
and putting
probably not putting them all the way
back together probably getting bored
before
i actually just loved going to the
hardware store
and just like looking at tools i had a
weird obsession with
springs i loved springs so seven before
you started taking stuff apart because
i've seen a video of you dissecting you
were
younger than seven taking apart one of
those like cards christmas cards that
made noises
oh yeah yeah yeah i was like i'm gonna
save this for something i'm gonna say
this for
circuitry and electronics yeah but i did
like going to hardware stores
and you know i was just generally happy
kid
i would have seven you had a baby sister
so
you probably were spending time being a
big brother
i assumed that you were very responsible
and very honest
and you just told things as they were
honestly i'm trying to remember what i
was like at seven that was like second
grade
i was extremely
tomboyish like soccer i don't know
is that like a is that still a word
people use i'm not sure
but i was climbing trees literally all
the time
we lived in an area where yeah where the
backyard
used to be like up against our backyard
it used to be like an old dump
and so like i was constantly just like
scavenging for stuff so me and my
friends had like
oh this is where like this is glass
mountain
i still cringe at glass mountain glass
mountain it was just like a hill with a
bunch of glass bottles on it
and you know we were just like making
tree houses and forts all the time so i
was like
outside all the time yeah it was great
yeah i was also tan when i was little i
was like
super tan because i was always outside
okay one more thing it's not really um
amusing but it's just interesting when
were you at your most primal state and
what did you learn from it i'll go first
okay
were making the rainbow bench and things
weren't going well and the little lizard
brain
part of my brain just took over and i
was very angry
i i just got very upset for some reason
and i don't know why
yeah i think we're just upset at me
and like things weren't going well and
it was one thing after another
and i just got very upset and angry
and i don't get that way much but it's
so interesting because like
i could feel both sides of my brain at
that moment it's like
the logical part of my brain said this
is gonna be fine you can fix this
just keep on going worst case scenario
it
doesn't look the best and whatever you
know it's like
um but like inside like the little like
ancient part of my brain was like
releasing angry chemicals
and like making me feel all flustered
and hot and stuff it was so interesting
that like that i could feel both of
those things at the same time
yeah i don't know yeah
i feel like when i think of those mo or
that kind of stuff i
my brain actually goes to times where i
was in like
like distress or like phys like physical
distress
so the times i think of are like
like the time after maker faire when we
both got really bad food poisoning and
we had to get on a plane
and i just remember being so so like
maybe primal isn't the right word but it
was like i did not care about
the human side of me i only cared about
like surviving
surviving yeah and i just remember like
being in the uber
on the way to the airport trying not to
like don't throw up
don't throw up sitting at and on the
first floor of the air
airport before we even could check in
and just having to sit down i just like
sat down on the floor against the wall
because i was like we both like went to
the restroom
and we were gonna meet each other but
like you went and sat down on some
chairs
and i didn't know where you were so i
just sat down on the floor next to the
restroom
and i was just like i'm good and i just
sat there for like 20 minutes
just not even having enough energy to
like go find you or care what anyone
thought about me in that moment
that was that was a tough moment it was
a tough time that was really tough
um what is the way i text say about me
the weird thing this is an interesting
thing it just leaves an interesting
conversation
when we were long distance dating oh we
texted
so much yeah when we were long distance
we were in communication pretty much
constantly
all the time when we were here but we
were working at different jobs
it was still pretty frequent not quite
as much because in the evenings
obviously we were around each other
yeah and we don't really text each other
no it's like we're here oh this is
okay this is so interesting if you
looked at our
text messages back and forth you would
be so confused you'd be so
lost let me pull it up real quick
because it's it's kind of amusing um
so caitlyn texted me a screenshot of her
windows
computer because i was looking at the
specs for it i was comparing it
we're chatting back about healthcare
like
coming up but it's not even like
chatting it's just like a link
a link with no context a screenshot with
no context
a draft email message a draft email with
a link to a google document
a link about another like draft email
yeah an address of a business contact
chatting about food you would think that
like we are not in love
at all you would think that like we're
just business and food
but the thing is that's it the thing is
so here's what we use our chat back and
forth
and we use google hangouts so it's like
on the computer and our phones yeah
so it's either we sit right next to each
other so it's either like oh can you
chat me a link
to that real quick or can you chat me
that you know
social media post draft so that i can
edit it real quick and we'll just chat
various
versions of like drafts of various posts
or emails back and forth
or it's like i'll just text an
image from my phone to evan so that i
can pull it up
on my own computer and it's just like a
random image because i want to like post
it on patreon or something
and i know if i just get a random image
i'm like she's probably using this as
like a message
i'm not sending you the image sending
myself the image
from my phone onto my computer because
that's easier than plugging my phone in
and pulling over the image
so let's see what can i do that you
can't and how do you feel about it
you can reach tall things
and you can i feel okay about it no i
can give a more serious yeah
yeah oh that's my amusing answer caitlyn
has
the power like like i said right at the
beginning
she can focus and she can like just get
stuff done and it really comes out
during the edit
and i could not do the edits that she
does i just don't have the patience
and like gumption to do that and i feel
grateful
that she fills that hole like she feels
that weakness of mine
like something that and i consider
myself
a generally tech-savvy-ish person but
next to you
i am a goose like i have
i have no knowledge that's a weird
example
i'm just i'm just i'm just a goose
i don't know i'm just a goose boy
you just especially since we started
streaming
oh yeah and all that like
so much of the technology we rely on
is so beyond me and it's kind of
gotten to that point because we kind of
had to divide and conquer and it was
something that you were more interested
in like i don't necessarily have
that big of a tech interest like it's
not something i'd
you know i've never cared about having
like the latest phone or the latest
computer or whatever and
um i like it in terms of
like i need it to do work and i want it
to work well
but i feel like you just have this huge
vast knowledge and often like because
your knowledge is so vast
you can often have it like an innate
understanding about something even if
it's new to you
you know um and
i'm very grateful that i can do that
because i can't do those things
i do like technology a lot and i think
that has that has really helped our
business
in a very lucky way because i've spent
hours and hours and days and days and
days just researching and looking
all this stuff up because a lot goes
into it oh my gosh
yep if i if my personality were a meal
what would be on the menu
and why if your personality
was a meal i just think of our favorite
foods yeah i'm trying not to think of
our favorite foods i always think mashed
potatoes because i like mashed potatoes
um but that's not your personality
because that would be
a meal what would be on that menu and
why
i think that no don't take this the
wrong way
yes
yours would be like
i'm trying to think of like the right
combination
soylent and nerds okay
because soylent if you don't know is
like a like
everything you need in a meal like in a
drink
in a drink and it's like very organized
and
it's everything you need very efficient
very efficient
yeah and when i think of caitlyn i think
of like she's she's
very efficient she's very like competent
but she's also
like when things are done is really fun
you know so it's like
you get like the efficiency and the the
goodness and like
the balance and everything is good but
then you also get like
a fun thing afterwards okay i don't know
here let me try yours yours is a it's a
seven course meal
seven course meal i should have thought
about my answer more
okay i'm gonna make it up as i go i
don't have it all here i have the
concept
i only thought of two things and i just
went okay so it
uh starts with breakfast tacos those
breakfast tacos have potatoes in them
potatoes are great then it goes to a
meal with
uh steak and asparagus and potatoes
because you were reminded by about how
great potatoes were
and then you're like man um steak is
also nice i'm gonna have some steak
tartare
that's great and then oh you know what
other raw things are good
sushi is good i'm gonna have sushi oh
rice is great i'm gonna have some fried
rice
so like like this one element from the
previous leads to the next
yeah thing that is a strong element of
my mind
one thing leads to another thing which
leads to another thing caitlyn will als
often play the game where like i start
singing one song and then it turns into
another
and she tries to guess what songs they
were
or like why one song turned into another
song yeah
yeah okay so i think that this is this
is
we have to like do one last thing
and then i think let's call it because
it's almost time for thing of the week
we're gonna end up with this if i were a
totalitarian dictator what would be my
first decree
my first degree would be
be nice to each other yeah
mandatory niceness
do one wholesome good deed every day
good deeds for all good deeds for all
give your cat some ham caitlyn would be
everyone adopt a cat
everyone give me your cats i'll take all
of them everyone give me all your cats
and that's when we move out to the rural
a rural place and we get a giant farm
and we surround ourselves with cats just
a bunch of cats that's that's
wasn't that one of your like dream goals
at one point in your life when i was
little i wanted to live with my mom and
own 200 cats as like my
goal for adulthood adulthood goal for
adulthood
live with my mom have 200 cats well guys
you know what time it is
[Music]
thing of the week yeah we didn't we
didn't forget that music
i was able to cue it up perfectly
so so my thing of the week is a mix of
the two of us
it has to do with technology and
organization
cable organizers there's a lot of
different
cable organizers you can get i have
bought
many of the different types and i did
all of that to find my favorite one and
i can pass it off to you
so you guys can save time so
this is is it's so simple it's just kind
of a
rectangular like clamp that's that's
like the the
space that has in it and you can fit
like eight cables in there or you can
just use it for one
it's multi-purpose it's versatile and
the first version of this i found
they had this foam adhesive ugh it was
weak
it tore badly all of this stuff now the
ones that i found now
they have very high bond adhesives
they're very
almost semi-permanent which is good and
bad
but generally more on the good side but
oh they're just so
great for organizing your cables links
down there
you're welcome organize your life can i
and i'm gonna add a
disclaimer to that because we've already
done a thing of the week that was your
favorite type of cable organizers
but there's different there's cable
organizers for different methods at that
point
you did the velcro ones which we've uh
before
those two combined the velcro ones are
great for like
when you were um like looping up a cable
over itself the ones you're talking
about now are more from mounting a cable
to a server
or cable routing like you're running a
cable from over here to over here you
don't want it dangling you want it like
in a
line or whatever um those two
combinations like for
attaching it like securing it to a
surface to a surface yeah so your
favorite for
for that type of cable organization um
my thing of the week
is a it's i think it's still kind of
newish i would still consider it newish
series on youtube
oh yeah yeah yeah bob binging with
babish is now
uh expanded into the babish culinary
universe and he has a new series called
stump sola
yeah so if you guys remember back in the
bon appetit days um one of the hosts
was sola and she's awesome and
she has now started working with andrew
from binging with babish
and they have the series where they spin
a wheel and there's various
challenges and then she makes the
challenge
and then like he kind of like judges it
at the end and they see if they were
able to stump her
i just think it's so cool that it's
really good youtube channels and youtube
businesses
are expanding and growing in these
interesting new ways
and like how how binging with babish now
has
like a production coordinator and like
multiple film people and editors and
it's so cool to see sola like see this
next
evolution for her too yeah you know like
finding like a
great like a great fit yeah i mean it is
it's really neat how these
platforms um are empowering
new interesting business opportunities
like this and
empowering people and like individuals
yeah to break away from big companies
and do things all by themselves yeah or
with like small indiv like small
teams small teams like andrew's team
yeah you know
like it's super cool and it's a really
fun show so far
yeah like uh a couple
examples just to kind of well there's
not too many episodes right now
but um the uh 18th century mac and
cheese
18th century mac and cheese was great
and then the other one was like they
everything was from like bodegas yeah
yeah yeah the bodega
[Music]
yeah the bodega seven course meal like
start with those two those have been my
favorite so far yeah
they're good um yeah good stuff well
again we'll have links to our thing of
the weeks in the description yeah
anyways thank you guys so much for
hanging out with us today
we appreciate that you guys take time
out of your day to hang out with the two
of us
um and by the way if you want to get
inside
on a prank that we have going go ahead
and rate this
podcast that you're listening to on
whatever podcast platform you're
listening to it on
a five stars we're trying to get up
there in the charts confuse people
people are going to find evan and
katelyn podcast
not know who we are what the heck this
is so well rated
and it's way up there in the the the
rankings i better listen to it
and then they're gonna be like what and
then we're gonna be like
we got them we're just trying to
disappoint people
all right guys hope you're having a
great day we'll look forward to seeing
you in the next episode
bye bye happy birthday
oh my gosh there's five more seconds of
this it's okay normally i fade us out